mayday ihr werdet heute wissenschaftlich
geprüft willkommen bei folge zwei von
wissenschaftlich geprüft made my day die
sprüche die dir den tag retten seines
zitate und weisheiten liebe und
beziehungen oder wissen gleich erinnert
sich noch jemand an meinen kleinen neue
trend über die hummeln die eigentlich
gar nicht fliegen können
lies dir was netz wirklich aufregt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
neben dem sie nicht die einzigen ihrer
art solche seiten gibt es viele aber
sind einer der größten und auf youtube
sind sie auch unterwegs ihr hauptkanal
hat über zweieinhalb millionen
abonnenten die sich für live sex fakten
unnützes wissen und vieles mehr
interessieren fakten
ich habe heute eines von major des
faktischen videos etwas genauer
anschauen und zwar sechs fakten über
männer die sie niemals zugeben würden
ich werde wieder prüfen welche dieser
fakten wissenschaftlich belegbar sind
welche nicht werde wissenschaftlich
approvals verteilen und am ende auch ein
gesamturteil für das ganze video geben
es kann mit der nummer 6 und die
durchschnitt sechs mal am tag am
häufigsten blieben die kollegen den chef
und die partnerin okay das ist fast
genauso gut wie ein mann denkt alle
sieben sekunden sex oder sowie möchte
man sowas bitte akkurat wissenschaftlich
bestimmen wie möchte man so etwas mit
dem häufigsten wieder lügen sind es gibt
eine gute und ist schon okay nehmen wir
das ganze doch einfach mal spaßeshalber
super ernst spaßeshalber super ernst und
überlegen uns wie man das ganze denn
prinzipiell messen könnte wenn man
wollte also sagen wir man könnte ein
lügendetektor im alltag an menschen an
bringen was man nicht kann und diese
lüge täte würde lügen immer akkurat die
diktieren was er nicht tut könnte man
trotzdem lügen wie es gibt gute und ist
okay du bist wahrscheinlich nicht direkt
ihren weil solche lügendetektoren
körperliche anzeichen von nervosität
aufzeichnen wie zum beispiel einen
erhöhten puls und ich glaube kaum dass
ihr jemand nervös wird wenn er die lüge
ist schon okay von sich gibt auch sonst
gibt es keinen wissenschaftlichen weg
lügen aufzudecken
die etwa keine ahnung ein hier in
scanner der die gedanken lesen kann
sowas gibt es auch nicht ich nehme das
ganze viel zu ernst jedenfalls was ich
damit sagen will um an zahlen zu kommen
wie männer lügen sechsmal am tag oder
frauen jugend dreimal am tag kann man
nur auf eine art und weise kommen
nämlich durch befragungen bei denen die
befragten eben selbst angeben wie oft
sie lügen und ihr könnt ich jetzt selbst
überlegen wie wissenschaftlich akkurat
das ist zürich sind unter dem made my
day video keine quellen angegeben für
ihre fakten aber glücklicherweise ist
made my day bekannt dafür sich
anderweitig zu inspirieren in diesem
fall von bright side gibt es auch auf
deutsch sonnenseite 15 fakten über
männer die sie nicht gerne zugeben und
zufälligerweise sind die sechs fakten
von made my day da auch mit drin
jedenfalls bin ich froh darüber denn auf
der englischen homepage von drei zeit
gibt es einen entsprechenden artikel mit
l fakten über männer und da sind die
selbst auch mit drin und hilfe gibt es
jeweils wenigstens ein paar sätze und
jeweils eine verlinkung zu der quelle
das ist doch schon mal was jetzt wird
euch in freunde der sonne die quelle für
diesen fakt ist eine umfrage von
twentieth century fox
eine der major filmstudios die diese
umfrage durchgeführt haben im rahmen
einer pr einer marketingkampagne für die
fernsehserie lie to me
aber abgesehen davon dass die century
fox jetzt kein wissenschaftliches
institut ist muss man nur einen blick
auf die top teams der männer werfen die
sind einfach wie auf so einer männer
karikatur von mario barth entsprungen
nummer zwei von den top ten lügen ist
das hier ist mein letztes bier männer
immer leid immer am laufen und lügen das
wissen wir doch alle lange rede kurzer
sinn fakt nummer eins beziehungsweise
nummer sechs weil bei mayday haben wir
immer einen countdown nada prüft akt
nummer fünf laut einer studie der
universität granada bevorzugen die
meisten wenn das schlanke frau die er
noch nicht abgemagert aussehen sondern
ein gesundes gewicht haben
hier ist auf einen artikel verlinkt über
die forschung einer spanischen
wissenschaftlerin von der universität
kanada ich habe mal geschaut was sie
sonst so macht sie beschäftigt sich vor
allem mit denen wie body image
selbstwahrnehmung und essstörungen in
ihrer psychologischen forschung dieser
artikel ist jetzt nicht besonders gutes
englisch übersetzt zumindest der titel
müsste eigentlich eher heißen men nike
mit dem paradies morgen oder so denn
hier geht es leider nicht um das was
gerade im video gesagt wurde sondern
vielmehr ums gegenteil nämlich dass
männern die schlankheit von frauen
wichtiger ist als es den frauen wichtig
ist hier wird zwar am ende erwähnt dass
männer in spanien durchaus auf ein
gesundes gewicht bei models stehen also
schon schlank aber gesund nicht zu dünn
allerdings ist das offensichtlich nicht
der fokus ihrer forschung auch nicht das
was sie herausgefunden hat sondern genau
im gegenteil nämlich dass männer die
schlanke frauen mögen deswegen leider
fakt nummer fünf morde prüft es gibt da
noch einen zweiten teil von facc nummer
fünf außerdem schrittes viel mehr ab
wenn eine frau beim ersten weltkriegs
die tiere erkältet ist typisch mann oder
wer zum teufel wieder gerne angehustet
übrigens ist die abneigung gegen husten
und niesen und andere zerstörungen von
körperflüssigkeiten ganz natürlich weil
wir uns ja auch vor potenziellen
krankheitserregern schützen möchten
indem wir sie vermeiden ich denke auch
nicht dass es jemals eine
wissenschaftliche studie zu gender und
verschieden in der wahrnehmung von
mussten geben wird habe ich sie richtig
verstanden sie möchten untersuchen ob
männer es unschön finden von frauen
angehustet zu werden ja genau und was
ihre hypothese außer loge sherlock und
für diese forschung möchten sie
steuergelder haben richtig also fakt
nummer 5 b ruft weil menschen nicht
gerne an gehostet werden und männer auch
menschen sind gut fakt nummer 44 34
männer stecken nämlich unterbewusst die
daumen nehmen die gärten oder die
hosentaschen um mädels zu beeindrucken
dieses verhalten lässt sich
interessanterweise auch bei einigen
affenarten beobachten
diese zeigen nämlich um ein weibchen auf
sich aufmerksam zu machen auf ihren
schritt da merkt man mal wieder dass du
vom affen abstammen
okay wir stammen nicht vom affen ab wir
haben evolution sich gesehen dieselben
vorfahren und warum muss ich jetzt
diesen affen wie nikon körpersprache
werden wissenschaftlich tatsächlich
schon lange untersucht körpersprache hat
wissenschaftlich gesehen also durchaus
hand und fuß aber vieles ist auch
einfach nur empirisch jedem immer wieder
aufhellen suche über schon wieder die
breitseite wurde auf diesen artikel
verlinkt es ist kein wissenschaftlicher
artikel aber hier ist in zwei grillen an
dem leben eine quelle davon ist dieses
paper dass sie
mit der wahrnehmung eines ausgestreckten
mittelfingers beschäftigt sehr
interessant hat jetzt nur nichts mit der
gürtel pose zu tun und zweitens ist ein
buch verlinkt bei diesem buch handelt es
sich um wird definitiv burg auf body
language von allan und barbara pease
barbara pease sind ein ehepaar
bestseller autoren bekannt von
bestsellern wie warum männer nicht
zuhören und frauen schlecht einparken
die immer wieder in der kritik standen
dass sie nicht wissenschaftliches als
faktion verkaufen und die beiden sind
auch keineswegs psychologen oder
wissenschaftler also ich denke wir
können sicherlich darauf einigen dass
diese pose diese typische pose in
unserem kulturkreis etwas typisch
männliches ist und dass das auch eine
art von imponiergehabe sein kann und das
ist durchaus dem fokus auf den
genitalbereich lenkt aber ob das jetzt
etwas uhr biologisches ist was die affen
auch machen oder ob das einfach
kulturell gesellschaftlich verankert ist
das müsste erstmal noch untersucht
werden also ich will jetzt nicht sagen
dass das ganze nicht stimmt aber darum
geht es ja bei wissenschaftlich geprüft
auch gar nicht anders geht hier darum ob
irgendwas wissenschaftlich belegt ist
und hier muss ich sagen
more research needed fakt nummer drei
hey hast du hier
du bist wie zufolge machen zuerst in der
endart aber wir haben noch es wichtig
genau das meint ich war es aber ich bin
jetzt hat noch nicht fertig ich komme
gleich nochmal
ok sorry auch wenn es fast keinen grund
zu geben wir immer bekommen gerne
komplimente von anderen
laut robert hörberg von der binghampton
universität in new york steigerten diese
komplimente nämlich enorme unser
selbstbewusstsein
herbert hat untersucht wie gut wie ihr
komplimente annimmt denn wie ihr
vielleicht auch selbst wisst ist es
nicht immer ganz einfach komplimente
anzunehmen sagen wir ich bekomme ein
kompliment cooles t shirt dann gibt es
grob zwei möglichkeiten damit umzugehen
nämlich entweder annehmen oder ablehnen
annehmen kann sein sich einfach zu
bedanken dankeschön sich bedanken und
noch irgendwas dazu sagen danke das ist
eines meiner lieblings das ist ein
prozess eine mischung aus kaktus und
brokkoli oder man kann natürlich auch
dankend und das kompliment zurück geben
danke jetzt auch oder man kann ablehnend
reagiert das heißt nicht unbedingt dass
man das kompliment nicht mag aber dass
man ebenso reagiert indem man es zum
beispiel relativiert das ist schon okay
ich mein was soll das überhaupt sein
onkel die oder im kaktus in dem man ist
komplett zurück weist das ist doch
albern oder indem man tatsächlich gar
nicht reagiert sondern sich einfach nur
um höhe führt robert irwin hat sich
jetzt angeschaut wie frauen männer
vielleicht verschieden mit komplimenten
umgehen und wie sie darauf reagieren
wenn die komplimente von frauen oder von
männern kommen und dabei hat er
interessanterweise festgestellt dass
komplimente die von männern kommen am
ehesten akzeptiert werden also
angenommen werden besonders auffällig
war der unterschied bei frauen die
komplimente bekommen wenn sie
komplimente von anderen frauen bekam
reagierten sie eher ablehnend
in die komplimente von männern bekamen
nahmen sie die ehe an
bei männern war der unterschied nicht
ganz so groß aber trotzdem da also
komplimente von anderen männern konnten
sie eher akzeptieren
komplimente von frauen wurden er
abgelehnt so die ergebnisse dieser
studie beinhalten zwar dass männer
komplimente von anderen männern leichter
annehmen das sagt aber nichts darüber
aus ob sie diese komplimente liebe hören
oder ob sie ihr selbstbewusstsein
stärken interessante studie nur leider
in diesem video interpretationen leicht
verfehlt deswegen leider nada prüft pack
nummer zwei ihren frauen nach freunde
besuchen die mit ihnen emotional auf
einer ebene stehen zu männern die die
gleichen interessen haben wie sie selbst
damit sind wenn er von schafften zwar
wenig oberflächlicher aber dafür um
wesentlich entspannter als
frauenfreundschaften es gibt durchaus
wissenschaftliche studien jetzt vorbei
die meisten davon relativ alt sind aber
da wurde festgestellt dass
männerfreundschaften tatsächlich
oberflächlicher sind oder zumindest kann
man es so interpretieren weil männer zum
beispiel selbst angeben dass sie mehr
freunde haben als frauen selber angeben
während frauen mehr zeit mit ihrer
freundschaftspflege verbringen das heißt
sie telefonieren öfter treffen sich
öfter zumindest mit ihren engsten
freunden wenn man sich alte studien
anschaut werden männerfreundschaften
immer beschrieben als diese großen rude
zeigt männer in größeren oberflächliche
'ran freundesgruppen und frauen in
intimen zwei jahre freundschaften mit
der besten freundin
das hatte natürlich auch damit zu tun
dass früher eben nur die männer zur
arbeit gegangen sind und da zum beispiel
arbeitskollegen hatten während die
hausfrau zu hause halt die eine beste
freundin aus der nachbarschaft hatte das
ist heute natürlich auch nicht mehr so
aber wenn man jetzt mal all diese
differenzierten betrachtungsweise mit
einbezieht dann ist das was in dem video
gesagt wird er durchaus wissenschaftlich
belegt darum geht es ja wie gesagt auch
und deswegen ein
er prüft packt mainz damit sind wir auch
schon höhere heutigen nummer eins und
der kleidung während die jungen alter
noch skinny jeans oder ähnliches tragen
weil wir das als modisch an dem wechseln
die meisten von konstruktion mit dem
alter zu lockerer und bequemer kleidung
ich wünsche mir dass sie da für mich ist
dieser punkt genau so muchitsch geologie
wie der puck mit dem busen ich denke
jetzt nicht dass man einen
gesellschaftswissenschaftler oder
psychologe sein muss um zu wissen dass
modetrends eher von jüngeren menschen
verfolgt werden und dass einem diese
modetrends auf irgend im alter auch eher
egal sind aber vielleicht meinen sie
auch gar nicht wissenschaftlich sondern
wollen hier einfach nur einen
offensichtlichen fakt mit aufnehmen aber
mal im ernst ich vor zehn jahren also
heute trage ich am liebsten in bequemen
woody und in jogginghose aber gut wenn
das die statistik sagt dann wird es
schon stimmen oder ob es eine statistik
dahinter steht made my day wenn ihr
offensichtliche tatsachen die jeder weiß
noch mal in einem video auf listen
möchtet wein aber dann seit wenigstens
so gut und lass die statistik daraus und
du nicht so als hättet ihr zahlen
übrigens ist die quelle für diesen fakt
laut drei zeit eine diskussion auf cora
fazit fakten ist nicht das beste wort
für diesen video titel gesamturteil nato
prüft natürlich gilt es review nicht nur
made my day sondern auch breitscheid und
sonnenseite die ja doch mehr als sechs
fakten haben gehe ich jetzt noch nicht
geprüft habe außerdem kam hier irgend
jemand von euch erklären welchen sinn
diese szene gibt müsste der jüngere mann
ich enge badehosen tragen oder so warum
ist dieses dann mehr so gut dass made my
day ist von bright side übernehmen
musste oder gehören sie doch irgendwie
zusammen ich verstehe das nicht falls
ihr noch vorschläge ab welches
youtube-video ich in zukunft
wissenschaftlich prüfen soll dann
schreibt es in die kommentare und jetzt
wird es wirklich zeit für die entkommen
da habe ich jetzt ja und bei aldi tief
im jahr angucken hey mailand wurde für
den grimme online award nominiert und es
gibt ein publikumspreis das heißt wenn
wir für uns abstimmen möchtet dann könnt
ihr das tun unter dem link in der video
beschreibung das war's auch schon dass
das hätten sich auch locker vorn machen
können
das ist wirklich nicht was drauf